U.S Special Envoy John Kerry is just
weeks from the cop 27 U.N climate Summit
in Egypt as scientists warn the world is
still on course for catastrophic
temperature rises he needs all the
momentum he can get right now every
government in the world is off course
every one of the 20 largest economies of
the world that represent 80 percent of
all the emissions are off Target at this
moment
new prime minister Rishi sunak won't be
much help he's just announced he won't
even be going to the summit it is
abdicating leadership not to go to cop27
we were the president of cop26 or the
more reason to push for King Charles to
attend despite then prime minister Liz
truss reportedly asking him not to I
think it would be very powerful I know
that his being there would make a
difference sure because he has
credibility because he's been a
long-term leader
there is much to contend with in
particular a global energy crisis driven
by the conflict in Ukraine complicating
the transition to clean power America is
currently exporting record volumes of
oil what credibility then do you have to
ask other countries to get off fossil
fuels well we're trying to stop Gap
those countries that have fuel needs as
a consequence of what Russia has done by
invading Ukraine so clearly that
disrupted the supply for them of needed
fuel to keep their economy moving and to
keep their homes heated and the lights
on the International Energy agency says
the energy crisis could end up
accelerating the Green Revolution but in
the meantime a lot of money is being
made in oil and gas
shell has just announced another round
of bumper profits as a result of high
oil and gas prices isn't it time for a
global windfall tax on fossil fuel
companies so that they can pay for the
damage they caused in relation to the
climate change crisis President Biden
feels very strongly that we need to have
fairness in this transition there has to
be just transition sounds like the US is
very open to the idea of a global tax on
fire I think I think the U.S is open to
ideas that are going to allow Justice in
the transition so that the average
citizen of countries are not getting
unfairly squeezed is the American
position that they're going to take a
look at everything that's being put on
the table and it will be part of a
conversation about Justice and fairness
and that will be the defining issue at
cop27 who is going to pay for the damage
inflicted by climate change
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News